it is the time of year when a lot of
people spend an unusual amount of time
thinking about death
in late october to early november there
are a number of holidays like the famous
halloween a day of ghosts ghouls and
trick-or-treating and jack-o-lanterns
but there's also the
very close to connected
days of all saints day and its companion
all souls day these three all fall at
around the same time and the
relationship and difference between them
can be a little confusing to a lot of
people i think most of you know what
halloween is and if you don't i've made
an episode previously about that which
you can check out but how about those
other ones all saints day and or souls
day what are these holidays where do
they come from and how are they
celebrated today
[Applause]
all saints day and all souls day are two
interconnected holidays that take place
in late fall specifically in early
november
they are at their core a christian
tradition all saints day is a day of
commemoration of the christian saints
and martyrs a practice that has a long
and interesting history and which is to
complicate things further very strongly
connected to the holiday of halloween
as such we must begin our exploration of
this topic in the ancient celtic pagan
festival known as sarwin
celebrated in pre-christian times and
beginning on october 31st this was a
festival that marked the end of summer
and the beginning of winter
and at this point of transition in the
calendar it was thought that the veil
between the world of the living and that
of the dead was at its thinnest this
meant that one could more easily
communicate with the dead and vice versa
and the festival seems to have very much
revolved around this idea we don't know
all that much with certainty about pagan
practices such as this since most of our
earlier sources come from second-hand
christian writers in the middle ages but
we do know that certain practices like
the lighting of bonfires took place as
well as the general orientation and
theme of this festival
on the other hand as a little religious
movement called christianity developed
in its earliest period they started also
to have feast days commemorating and
celebrating the saints and martyrs of
the faith this is thus a tradition that
goes back to the very earliest days of
christianity
and when this little religion which at
this point had become the state religion
of the largest empire in the world
started to spread to new lands through
missionaries there were different
techniques used to convert the
population in these new lands
and one of the most common and
successful ways to do this has always
been to meet people halfway
what i mean by this is that one would
often take an already existing tradition
or custom and give it new christian
meanings or christian clothing
to christianize customs already present
in the local community
this of course makes it appear like
conversion doesn't make one hat to give
up all of one's entire life and culture
and makes that process a lot more simple
and appealing one often quoted example
of this is that christmas the
celebration of jesus's birth was placed
on december 25th in the roman world
which was the same day that there was
already an existing festival that
celebrated the birth of the gods soul
invictus in the roman empire this theory
is widely rejected by scholars today
however as the evidence doesn't really
point in that direction anymore but
another example one that seems a lot
more likely is that when the christians
came to the british isles the festival
of celebrating the dead saints started
to be celebrated specifically on
november 1st at the same time that the
local custom of sauron was already
taking place
the connection to the world of the
deceased and both of these traditions is
a likely reason that the christians
chose to place the holiday at this
specific time in another attempt to
appropriate local practices and
incorporate them into christianity
rather than eradicate them completely
thus all saints day as we know it was
born and eventually spread to other
places in europe and western christendom
in general
another name used for the holiday was
all hallows day which means that the day
before on october 31st was all hallows
eve which is where we get the name
halloween
and on the day after all saints day on
november 2nd is celebrated all souls day
a festival where one commemorates the
souls of those departed in a general
sense not just the saints as such but
every
soul every faithful soul or any any
person who has died or passed away is
commemorated on all souls day on
november 2nd
this triad of days all hallows eve or
halloween all hallows or saints day and
all souls day is sometimes together
referred to as a hallow tide so as you
might imagine the connection and
difference between these three
somewhat separated days can appear
complicated and confusing to some people
and while it is true that the festival
of halloween originally had its origins
in the
pagan festival of sarwin aside from its
place in the calendar so taking place at
the same time of year there is
very little left of sarwin in what we
know as halloween in fact most of the
things that we associate with halloween
different rituals and imagery and so on
actually comes from later christian
periods and the celebration of all
saints day so for example
trick-or-treating likely originates in a
practice called souling where groups of
people would travel between houses and
singing
asking for
blessings or asking for
prayers for the dead as well as for
objects like asking for apples or soul
cakes as it was known and the famous
jack-o'-lantern which is kind of the
poster
figure for halloween also has its
origins in these practices as people
would often carry with them hollowed out
turnip lanterns as they were going from
house to house so many of these
traditions actually come from a
post-christian period rather than from
the pre-christian sovereign in any case
halloween and all saints day slash all
souls day are usually pretty clearly
distinguished today halloween is a pop
culture infused celebration sometimes
associated with consumerism while all
saints and souls day is a solemn
christian day of commemoration and these
days are widely celebrated across europe
even today however they can look pretty
different depending on where for example
all souls day is also often known as the
day of the dead and in mexico this has
evolved into a very vibrant and unique
tradition of its own strongly flavored
by local culture as seen for example in
the popular pixar film coco
but in a place like sweden which is
where i'm from the celebration of these
holidays looks quite different and it
can also tell us a lot about
how swedes relate to religion and
secularism in sweden both halloween and
all saints day are widely celebrated by
people but they are very clearly
distinguished from each other most of
the time
halloween takes place on october 31st
like
it always does in most places but all
saints day does not actually take place
on the traditional date of november 1st
instead since the 1950s all saints day
actually takes place on the first
saturday in november this means that
every few years the dating of these
holidays do line up in the traditional
way so if halloween falls on a
friday on october 31st that means that
all saints day will fall the next day on
saturday november 1st but if halloween
falls on a sunday like this year that
means that all saints day is celebrated
almost a full week later on november 7th
on this saturday it's weird but that's
how we do it over here and in sweden the
connected holiday of all souls day
supposed to take place on november 2nd
kind of isn't really a thing
the church of sweden does recognize it
as an official day of commemoration but
for the regular swede all saints day and
old souls day are kind of mashed
together in fact what we call all saints
day in sweden
is actually more akin to old souls day
in practice
now sweden is quite a secularized
country it is often ranked among the
most secularized in the world and this
is definitely true to some degree
relatively few swedes identify with a
particular religious denomination and
are often only very mildly engaged in
religious questions but as scholarship
has shown like that by scholar of
religions david turpiel this does not
mean that people don't believe in a
divine higher power for example or that
they have abandoned religious traditions
not at all in fact
christian holidays like all saints day
christmas or easter are still very
actively and passionately observed by
many swedes today but are often drained
of any outright connection to teachings
or imagery from christianity
christmas is a big deal in sweden but to
many the birth of jesus christ isn't
really that relevant or considered
for most the holiday is about gathering
together as a family eating certain
foods
getting presents and even watching
donald duck on television
much more so than it has anything to do
with christ
a term that has been coined to denote
this kind of phenomenon is
post-christian
many swedes are so-called post-christian
in the sense that they have stopped
identifying with the organized religion
of christianity as such but still engage
and participate in a culture that is
infused with christianity take part in
rituals that originate in the religion
or have certain emotional attachments to
these things we love our rituals and
traditions just don't get too religious
about it
all saints day is the same and that is
what i mean when i say that too many
swedes all saints day is really all
souls day because when all saints day is
celebrated few ever think about the
saints and martyrs of christianity
ask any sweden they will tell you that
on all saints day we simply remember
those who have passed
in other words the more overtly
christian aspects of the holiday is
downplayed in favor of a more general
commemoration of the dead on all saints
day families will often gather together
many will visit the graves of loved ones
who have passed perhaps a grandmother or
a father
candles are lit and placed by their
graves and the day is spent trying to
remember and appreciate those loved ones
who have moved on
in stockholm in particular it's quite
common to visit a large cemetery called
shukugorden here as well as in many
other cemeteries most of the graves are
covered with candles creating a kind of
sea of lights in the darkness at least
after the sun has set which is quite a
beautiful sight
even if you don't have a loved one in
this cemetery in particular it has
become a local custom of sorts to visit
on this day to walk around looking at
the lights and the graves
it's a quite solemn atmosphere one where
people will try to give an extra thought
to those who have passed as well as
mortality in general a kind of
collective memento morai
as we saw too many people this has
little to do with christianity but
instead takes the form of a more
universal and secular day of
commemorating the dead even though the
tradition itself clearly does come from
a christian background of course the
church and those active in it will
emphasize it on more clearly christian
grounds and often have services and
vigils during these days in a more quote
unquote traditional way but the varied
ways that this fascinating tradition is
celebrated can really show us how
religions always impact and are impacted
by different local contexts but can also
give us a look into the way that
religion and secularism function and are
in conversation with each other in
contemporary post-christian sweden
i hope those celebrating have a
meaningful all saints and old souls day
and that we are blessed by the memories
of those who are not with us anymore
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you